so you
[Music]
can perfect
[Music]
perfect yo what's up guys welcome back
to the episode of the dope as usual
podcast i am thomas dobaziola whatever
you want to call me i'm here with marty
o'neil what's up what's up we had to
leave the f words out because youtube
said
stop cussing so much in the intro
all right that's basically what the
email is like yo heavy cursing not a
good look so
for all the advertisers all the
advertisers for the first 30 seconds
today we'll be nice we'll pretend like
the teacher's here
it's been about 30 seconds
hey [ __ ] you kid
that's how i'm like oh jesus hey you're
a [ __ ]
so
um
here we go this first 30 seconds over
we'll do the 10 minute nice guy clock
just to be safe
and um we'll get on to it i will start
what we're going to be talking about
this episode was about to be completely
different
we'll do the episode still
[Music]
marty's wife april was supposed to do
the episode yesterday
but some [ __ ] happened
which caused this whole thing to change
so
get ready
we're both not sure where this is going
we there's no notes that is off
we weren't even planning on doing this
at all we were gonna mess with like we
were gonna have to miss uh
yeah we're about to miss an episode
for monday but then marty calls me last
night says hey how would we just do this
so this is the episode today
friday night
we're planning the april episode
saturday morning i'm hitting up marty
take it away
yeah man
well this
i just
i wanted to come in and do this today
just because i feel like i have about 20
years worth of [ __ ] to get off my chest
behind the [ __ ] and you weren't allowed
you weren't going to ever talk about it
dude
we were really open there's stuff marty
does not talk about because like we
always say certain people are alive some
people might go to jail
it gets hard so now that you can talk
freely which is not like a cool thing
it's not like super stoked i just know
there's a lot of kids out there
exactly go through similar [ __ ]
and
might help them
navigate it
so yeah my mom died yesterday that's
that's the big [ __ ] event pretty
unexpectedly
so i woke up to that call
about six in the morning
you're already awake no no
saturday yeah
yeah so
you know it was it's
a long story that could take up a whole
podcast because it's like her story is
just
very unique and there's a lot that i
haven't been able to talk about like we
said kind of like my whole life though
not just there's [ __ ] that literally
only i've only talked about to you in
april yeah
which is crazy so
but
yeah my mom was awesome though like just
uh off top
until i was you know throughout my whole
childhood she was responsible for me
having an awesome childhood like i
always say like
just simple like
for for
for the most part
because there was also this layer when i
was like 16 that
i went and stayed out for a couple weeks
with my cousins in detroit
and that was the time or for the lead up
yeah your mom is the golden mom until
you're about 16. yeah you go visit your
face as far as i knew yeah she was great
like i said it was just us it was so
simple it was three of us
nothing
i i didn't go through anything traumatic
in my childhood all like that like it
was [ __ ] just real simple we didn't
have money or anything but i was always
had what i needed and it was fine
yeah it was normal couldn't be more
normal than just regular and that's all
you can [ __ ] really ask for because
that just puts me in position to be a
successful person of course if that's
when i was when i was 16 i went to
detroit he was real sick and they were
like my cousins were in town i think or
maybe they just came and got me and they
were like you can come hang out for a
couple weeks it was [ __ ] awesome it
was amazing actually it was like the
best time of my life because they let me
drive their cars and [ __ ]
that yeah it was my same cousin that had
given me the computer
and but this was before that
oh this is pre-lap pre-drastic graphics
spark yeah i was like
that happened when i was like 19 this
was like 16. got you
so
yeah they took me to an eminem concert
eminem gg unit kid rock missy elliott i
remember that one tour yeah no it was a
one night one night i thought kid rock
was did stuff with eminem before he
probably did but this particular show
was a one-of-one remember kid rock with
the rappers went yeah okay the [ __ ] was
epic you can imagine downtown detroit oh
yeah they just pick you up my cousin
she's cool like i knew my cousin when i
was younger she was a little bit older
than me but then like we're going to
talk about throughout my adolescence i
didn't really have a lot of touch with
her in contact with her so
it was
like even better because they're like my
younger but older cousins who i knew
when i was little like i said my first
cassettes were all eyes on me crazy sexy
cool that was her giving it to me her
brother's the one who gave me the
computer oh god you know like your
cousins that you wish you grew up with
yeah they were great they lived in
detroit though after
after i was you know they moved there
after i was like five six or seven years
old or whatever
but
she kind of like put some news on me
that just
[ __ ] impacted the rest of the course
of my life on i don't i'm glad she did
but it also put me in a [ __ ] up
predicament
because i think
this was when i saw pulp fiction for the
first time her her ex-husband showed it
to me and i think it was actually after
the eminem concert that same [ __ ]
night i'm pretty sure it changed your
whole life yeah we're back at her house
and [ __ ] and she's like you know your
grandfather was a real
creep right like and she started going
down this whole path of all this
horrible [ __ ] he had done to her
and all my relatives
and mom's dad yeah
yeah and
it kind of made some sense as to why
[ __ ] the dynamic of my family was all
alive at this time no he died when i was
seven oh she didn't really remember him
not really i was a little kid he was old
but
she put all this news on me and then was
like but you don't you can't say
anything don't say anything your mom
never brought this up ever no i had no
clue that any of this happened
before but i from the from the time i
was little until the time he died i was
over there almost every day with him
yeah
i was i basically lived there for like i
was there almost every day of my life
nobody
everything was just fine
nobody's just pretending it never
happened
that
i think in a lot of like
a lot of families a lot of [ __ ] like
that goes
untalked about
or
i don't i don't know because this is
what this is what hasn't made sense to
me my whole this is the crux of the
problem yeah is that
yeah she like i guess at his funeral
went up to my grand her mom and like
said something to her
and then literally from that point never
talked to her again
after the funeral
and
removed me completely from
that whole aspect of my family something
happened at his funeral
that she
literally wrote off
her whole family for life and literally
took it to the grave
but that you know she never wouldn't
talk to your grandma again she never
talked to her again
your grandma is still alive today yes
she just found out about this
does this happen
yesterday
dude this whole day has been very weird
and the [ __ ] is i've talked to like 40
different times yeah you're the only
person i talk to i really appreciate
everybody i reached out yesterday
on instagram and
people that i know from buffalo and [ __ ]
my family
yeah because
so anyway
at that same time my dad was really
super sick like i was talked about he
kept having these stints where we
thought he was gonna die you're back at
16. yeah and seven was the funeral
mm-hmm never saw your cousins again
until 16. yeah but it wasn't like oh it
was never a verbal thing i just just
went away yeah okay just kind of like i
had no clue that any of this was
happening until my cousin told me all
this [ __ ] when you're 16 basically an
adult
yeah
i was dealing i mean i was dealing with
my dad at that time it was it was like a
new kind of thing but it was real bad in
terms of like
just what he was going through and all
the dynamic in my house
but you know
after a while it was so up and down for
so long that it like
took a horrible toll on her by the time
i met april
uh things were starting to get weird
with your mom mm-hmm okay because you
told me a few things i think i think
before we went over it your mom is super
obsessed with your dad yeah like wow
[ __ ] like she loved your dad so [ __ ]
much yeah everybody knows that yeah so
when he was getting sick she started
getting [ __ ] up yes
yeah was it like a pill thing or just it
was mental it was both okay watching him
go through what he was going through
she had her own physical issues she was
dealing with that she had like pain meds
for
we had probably the highest level pain
meds you could have in our house for
years
so i think she probably had a pretty
serious thing going with the pills
and
like in the way that people embrace like
jesus and like a religion
she was like that but with like reiki
and like metaphysical [ __ ] too she
considered herself like a healer and
like a yeah damn near like a uh
psychic never talked about this before
because we couldn't
but i think it's so wild that your mom
was so like committed to that yeah
energy [ __ ] that she was into she would
have swore she was a professional healer
like she didn't actually practice it
but like that was who she was she was
like my whole childhood your mom was a
hippie yeah and your dad was too though
yeah
but you know my whole childhood was very
much like her her all over him and him
like kind of just like
it was him and his guitar like he was
just very neutral but her whole identity
was being his husband she was like or
his wife
with him being being a musician like
well that makes sense now that i know
your dad was so [ __ ] well known for
being a famous musician
she was just in awe i think right yeah
she just was totally fine just
supporting him doing whatever she worked
like a bunch of different jobs you know
it was never she didn't have like a
career it was just she didn't care about
that really you know
um but
she was also somebody that always gave
me really great advice there was advice
she gave me growing up like watch that
[ __ ] kid oh really like and i would
be like what please you'd like and then
i would always end up realizing like
damn she was right how did she
how'd she see that tell me about this
yeah she was like me and her were super
close for not as close as me and my dad
were
i couldn't help but tell her everything
that was going on in my life i remember
like in high school [ __ ]
for the most part you know then i
started getting a little bit older and
then you start kind of i don't know if
it's every kid or you start living like
a double life between who you are in
front of your parents and who you
actually are every single yeah
[Music]
like two yeah i don't but
you know i got out of the house pretty
early uh
um
19 18. you know when i met april and
right around that same time april even
off the bat almost was like
something a little off with your mind
i'm like no
but after a couple months i was like
there is something yeah yeah i didn't
i was starting to beat an adult and
she was like dealing with everything she
was dealing with
and uh
she just started being real loopy and it
was hard to have a real conversation
with her
and it became very just superficial
of just whatever she wanted to talk
about basically
and
yeah because she would talk to you as if
you believed exactly how she did
because you gotta remember she has been
her whole life this
healer of non-farm school and now she's
getting on pills
that must have and like nothing's
working for my dad really i mean it is
because he didn't like die right away
yeah but at the same time she's
she's somebody that's always looking for
a literal
like explanation of why
like
like every like everything happens to a
reason to the point that
when bad things happen she takes it
super personal i was like that too for a
while i had to think my way out of that
like she really she would really like
and then let me let me make sure i'm
keeping this on track here so
16 just tells you what's going on you
come back home and go
and my mom was so fragile did you bring
it up to her no oh okay no [ __ ] no i
couldn't bring up anything to her
early on april's like why don't why
can't like we don't have normal
conversations really i act different in
front of her there's just this elephant
in the room that was starting to form of
how horrible it was what my dad was
going through and how she was like going
off the deep end
and very early on i was like because she
would do certain [ __ ]
and
in a normal relationship you would like
talk about it but i'm like trust me
don't we don't want to bring we don't
want to go off track with this trust me
the 1950s family yeah i was trying to
navigate i just thought she was she was
just so like delicate and so like
at her [ __ ]
point yeah that
it became a very different relationship
over the next couple years
than i had growing up
and uh
when that whole situation with jamella
happened
she really took his side in the ship
which and i remember in slow motion
getting back
cops are there at ariana's birthday
party like i told you and her like
defending him and [ __ ] like he had her
all wrapped up in his [ __ ] and like
playing both sides of the fence and but
he thinks he's in the right so it's not
like he's being a devious she was
feeling that way too they were both
together not liking me starting a family
she wanted me to like slow because
you're dead yeah but even like after he
died i was like why don't we why don't
you let us move in to the i was ready to
we were going to move into his old
studios attached to her house she was
like she said no so we went and stayed
in new jersey for a couple months and
[ __ ] and then we came back and stayed
with her and you know in my dad's old
studio and [ __ ] but she didn't april
couldn't be more [ __ ] amazing to her
period let me like i can't stress that
enough she's better to her than i was
a lot of the times
april it happens that way though when
somebody doesn't when you're in your
other like your spouse
like your exact thing like when my mom
first started talking again rosie you
just have to take over conversations
while i'm just like
i don't fully trust you yet so yeah you
know it was kind of like that it has to
take over just to make it like we said
to humor the person so they don't freak
the [ __ ] out and leave yeah
and then i started just really resenting
the fact that she would like she had
this whole aspect to her where
the main thing was like she would never
ever
consider the notion of going to therapy
she should have been in therapy since
she was a kid we should have both been
in therapy since i was a teenager
she should have been in therapy beyond
me being a teenager extensive intensive
therapy
counseling she would [ __ ] laugh at
the idea of doing that like she had an
ego i don't know if it was ego but it
was just like
if i were to bring it up when i brought
it up to my aunt a couple days ago like
she needs she [ __ ] laughed
like she would never consider
and she would also be she would also
really really eventually hold grudges
so it was like a front and i'd hated
that
that or like her email signature was
peace begins with me it was always this
piece this piece that but she held a
grudge
yeah that was like her whole
front facing if you met her she'd be
great
after talking to her for a little while
you'd be like
there's a little something off
then but if she like i saw her get
wrapped up in like my
family's issues so she never ever ever
ever talked to them again
some of them she never talked to my
grandma again she never talked to some
of her sisters again
you know she ended up like reconnecting
with like two of my aunts kind of down
the line as i like
okay so
22 your dad passed away
you move
to california at what
two years later yeah two years later and
your mom stays
at first so we had this horrible thing
of drama the whole situation we talked
about on my last episode that happened
right before we left and it really had
me and her in deep turmoil and that was
the first time that i let her know that
i knew all that [ __ ]
you told her yeah
because jamal was spreading these really
horrible [ __ ] disgusting rumors
throughout my family and i went over
there and it [ __ ] killed me like
she's sitting there
she's all we're all mad at each other
over [ __ ] nothing
literally yeah all this [ __ ] is over and
[ __ ] nothing
and i just put it all out there
and she's like to see her [ __ ]
sobbing crying and sitting there talking
about the [ __ ] was everything i always
wanted
she had she acknowledged it
and she just acknowledged like uh
that she really blamed her mom and she
blamed like of course all the [ __ ]
none of my other family like
holds this resentment but my mom had
this
horrific
resentment
but then then that morphed into
resentment for me because i'm like well
then why the [ __ ] was i over there my
whole life exactly and that was a
question i never got to ask because i
don't think she could have handled it
because there was times
okay i'm getting ahead of myself
you brought it up to her that's where
we're at right there
yeah after that yeah
so things got got a little better after
we addressed all that i don't know why
that came out in that time that was that
was a couple months before we moved
and then we had enough we had a falling
out as i was moving to california
because we tried to have this big-ass
garage sale to sell all of our [ __ ] and
it took us [ __ ] three weeks to get
all our [ __ ] organized and
you know labeled and all the [ __ ] ready
for the garage sale we go to the garage
show and it's [ __ ] pouring rain out
so we don't sell any of our [ __ ] maybe
some of it we sold some on facebook it
was a [ __ ] massive ordeal to pack up
to move to california just leaving
behind one of our cars
all the [ __ ] so she ended up getting all
butthurt about us leaving behind some
[ __ ] in the garage and my my one of my
cousins ended up handling it you know he
took the [ __ ] or whatever
it was toys and clothes
but as i was moving out her here me and
her were at some stupid [ __ ] odds for
the first couple weeks of me being out
here and then we got back on the phone
and
kind of reconnected a little bit it was
over nothing so it was fine and then
after about a year she moved out here
too
oh and then lived with you guys for how
long well she lived like in santa ana in
an apartment so she had her own life out
here she lived out here for a couple
years oh she was doing her healing and
[ __ ] out here no she never actually like
did that professionally she had like
cubicle jobs and [ __ ] but she [ __ ]
hated working
like when my dad was sick i don't know
how she did it she would take off for
[ __ ] years at a time
years literally between her back pain
and whatever she had going on and like
his stuff i don't know how she [ __ ]
finagled it she would get
big long stretches of time off
and still be working for the job
she just like i don't know that's just
always how that's how it was at least
after she got out so she wasn't around
you guys she would just leave
she would leave for years at a time no
no off her job like on like
work leave sorry yeah yeah yeah gotcha
yeah she so she was just home but she
would keep her job like i don't know how
she did that [ __ ]
but when she moved out here she started
kind of doing that [ __ ] again to her
[ __ ] job she was working
so
that became you know but it was cool she
had a life all i wanted for her was to
have a life of her own again because
when he died like there was weeks and
months after he died that i thought she
was gonna commit suicide
she was doing a bunch of weird [ __ ] she
was going to
like niagara falls and having [ __ ]
seances and [ __ ] with her friend elaine
tried to talk to him yeah they that they
thought they were talking to him they
really thought they were
they might literally bro
i don't [ __ ] [ __ ] know your mom
might have been on some [ __ ]
but let me keep going with this so but
it wasn't a it didn't feel [ __ ]
healthy at all it felt like
off the demon yes
so she had elaine elaine her friend
elaine
was the reverend for our wedding
for your wedding yes oh wow
and we were like we didn't know who we
were gonna get we don't go to church or
anything so we're like yeah she can do
it she's your friend that's fine she's
like
sanctioned or whatever
mid-wedding she started [ __ ]
freestyling mid-ceremony
she started using her friend yeah you
ever told me this yeah she did she's
like she's trying to freeze that
going off the [ __ ] beaten path of
what you do at a wedding she was like uh
as we're saying our vows she's like i
wed the trough she said something about
a trough in the vows mid vowel me and
april both like [ __ ]
okay we said it i wet my trough
and then like the ceremony went out and
she's like okay now we're gonna do the
rings and she's like jamal
and jamal pulled out these [ __ ] like
hula hoop things that were like
intertwined with each other and
jamelle's standing there like uh
yeah he didn't know what the [ __ ] and it
was just this [ __ ] she added in without
letting us know and then afterwards she
was like she literally said i think i
was channeling april's grandmother stop
with this old time language that just
came out during the ceremony stop it
mom's friend this is her best friend
this is her only friend
this was a friend she added on when i
was like i don't know 18 19. i see your
mom
being more
[Music]
like miss lippy from billy madison with
things but super nice
yeah she was like she looked normal i
feel like she was like a normal lady but
like we've seen two of the clicks and
[ __ ] but there was something
there was something so her friend ruined
your [ __ ] wedding no she didn't i
don't want to make it seem like that it
was just [ __ ] weird and we laughed
about it
so then
all right let me keep this going here so
just keep that in mind that was
basically her only friend her friend
elaine like so they both think that they
can levitate [ __ ] basically they think
they have special
likes like uh telepathic [ __ ] powers
which also pisses me off because it's
like
all the [ __ ] we're going through you
want to sit here and act like you know
nobody knows i'll only sit here and be
cool with you acting like you know to a
certain [ __ ] point because nobody
really knows
you can't talk to me
like you literally for sure know what's
going on in the afterlife and expect me
to just
accept that that's just what you were
dealing with yeah
yeah but in a weird loopy [ __ ] kind
of way and she was still so i feel like
it's a weird fragile
so now
let me keep this going
hey what's up guys this is a quick break
from this super [ __ ] intense episode
marty and i are introducing a new
sponsor to the dope as usual podcast
this is mybookie.com my bookie yes
exactly what you're thinking is what it
is this is an online gambling site for
everyone out there that does online
gambling online uh roulette tables card
games they have that so this is not just
for sports but for all you sports people
out there let me get into this next part
tyron woodley jake paul
we all know about jake paul and all that
but he he's got a chin all right so far
he's doing pretty good so for all the
people all the naysayers all the pro
jake paul people this is the time to
place your bets dope as usual podcast
has teamed up with mybookie and we're
giving you a code the code dope as usual
will let you double your initial deposit
up to a thousand dollars when it comes
to odds or prop bets my bookie has the
best odds for the woodley and jake paul
2 fight as i said earlier if you want to
take a bet on this you can use our code
and it lets you double your deposit up
to a thousand dollars for this fight my
boogie slogan is bet anything anytime
anywhere so for all you fools out there
that are just constantly betting with
your friends get online and use our code
so big shout out to mybookiemybooky.com
for being part of the dope as usual
podcast back to the episode
so she has her own life in california
she has
a job and she's being a great
grandparent every weekend she's taken
ariana to go hang out at her apartment
and they're doing
grandparent kid [ __ ] beautiful
mind you i've been cut off from my whole
family my kids don't have interaction
with my side of the family only
literally only april sat it's not like
you're like why did you just go talk to
him it's weird when you haven't talked
to him in 20 years you're like let's be
friends and they all have this weird
relationship with her so you're the kid
they don't want to have her set off on
some [ __ ] vendetta against them is
what i realized later on also [ __ ] not
to mention my aunt and uncle
invented screen printing they were they
would be doing the coolest [ __ ] you
could imagine summer job right there all
the super bowls all the huge concerts
all the [ __ ]
all the cool [ __ ] like
they had a mansion
you know it would have been it would
have been cool
uh so
[Music]
and on top of them being awesome people
and you know the rest of my family is
really cool
when i came back from when i went back
to buffalo for the first time i went to
a family reunion for the first time and
i saw all my family there yeah they're
just 23 for no this was when i went back
to buffalo for the first time after
being here for five or six years so it
was like
uh
late 20s yeah
and they were all just being a [ __ ]
family you know like it was amazing to
see all the kids and my cousins the
older people my grandma's there they're
like i thought it might be the last time
i see my grandma never talked to her
before because your mom cut you off your
grandma yeah i i see your grandma at all
i
reconnected with them like briefly
before i moved out here i went and saw
him on christmas so from seven to like
22 you never saw your grandma on
christmas or nothing yeah [ __ ] you guys
were cut off yeah big time
but yeah it was never talked about yeah
he never said [ __ ] about it like he was
he didn't give a [ __ ] i don't think yeah
or he just understood how
deeply passionate she was about this
[ __ ] vendetta yes but nobody ever
explained to me what the [ __ ] was going
on it's crazy your dad is playing guitar
and meets the lady doing hippie dances
and they got [ __ ] married yeah that's
exactly what happened
wow yeah
cause yeah if you if you look back at
them they were like the hippies that
looked like the manson hippies back in
the day like they had the long hair and
they were all [ __ ] like
you know i don't know what they were on
that's what i'm getting at
i don't know they both lived out here
they lived in la and before like my mom
would tell me that she used to literally
go to that bus station
pick somewhere to go and go live there
wow [ __ ] like that
for a couple years or whatever grew up
in the 60s yeah
yeah and she just she grew up
you know i'll get to this but she wrote
a letter
oh we'll get to it she like described
crazy [ __ ] yeah so she has her own life
she's picking up ariana which is super
[ __ ] cool your whole family's cut off
you met them before you came back family
reunion
everybody's super cool
[Music]
then what changes when you're here in
california that she's not being the
great grandparent so yeah so we moved or
i came back to california everything's
still going great and then we decided
we're gonna try to buy a house in austin
this is recent yeah yeah this was this
was right before i met you yeah oh [ __ ]
so we moved to austin
now i was like i told her explicitly
multiple times we're going to be back
we're going down there to buy some
properties it might be a year it might
be a [ __ ] month we're gonna be back
she's in like uh
one of those senior apartment complexes
where your rent is like capped april had
her on a [ __ ] waiting list
to go live on the ocean down in dana
point at a similar thing you got to be
on a waiting list for like [ __ ] two
years to get in april had put her on the
waiting list that was like maybe six
months out
so we're like
just chill
let us go figure this out we might buy a
house down there either way we're coming
back for sure that was always the
plan getting ahead of myself here there
was some incidents some big incidents
where it really made me question like
her honesty
because
here's a really good example we want to
visit april's family in florida this is
before texas
we have our friend house sitting like
looking after our cat and [ __ ] she comes
to the house and she's like something
smells like it's burning i just want you
guys know i wasn't like smoking weed in
your house or nothing like something
smelled like it was on fire in your
[ __ ] house when i came
so then we
like talked to my mom and she goes yeah
i i stopped over at the house and um i
got the baby a new bottle
and
the strangest thing i went to sanitize
the bottle and i was boiling it
and i'm just sitting there and looking
at my phone and you know the next thing
i know it was like it was it was kind of
smoking
the water had evaporated
now i look out in my outdoor garbage can
and i see a pan that was on [ __ ] fire
the pan
is singed
as if the the bottle was
melted and is one with the pan now the
pan was on [ __ ] fire it had to have
been on fire for a while
and by how when we came home we could
smell it in the house
so i like questioned her on it even at
this point still i'm very [ __ ]
eggshells with her and it's annoying to
april because we don't like communicate
really normally there's still
up through her living in california
still a giant [ __ ] elephant in the
room that i can't address that i'm my
resentment's also kind of building as
time goes on
because i'm seeing her
do a bunch of vengeful [ __ ] to people
not to mention everything we've already
brought up about me and you know kind of
putting me in harm's way at a young age
and then
circling around to be butthurt about it
if you're gonna be if you're gonna hold
the vengeance you gotta do it from the
start you can't let your kid you can't
drop me off at all times yeah and then
circle back to your vengeance of course
but anyway she got real [ __ ] like
defensive and mad that i like questioned
her about the pan the next day the very
next day now she's in the hospital
now she had a heart attack at work hold
on before because your mom did pass away
of an actual heart attack
i think so so far
your mom does pull fred sanford [ __ ] i
talk about fred stanford as in she fakes
heart attacks when she doesn't want to
continue the conversation we think
that's what happened because
in my experience you don't go in for a
heart attack and then have them
let you go the same evening basically
and then not have any like follow-ups or
anything or if you'd like it also does
it fits into a pattern of her health
kind of deteriorating but it was just so
cool this happened like two or three
times where you guys are having an
argument something would happen that i
would have to call out like was our
house on fire or no why were you even
here you weren't even supposed to be
here why are you boiling a bottle like
it's 1930 you have your kids yeah nobody
was in the house there's no bottle
there's no baby needs a bottle there we
weren't even there like for when you
guys get home we have plenty of bottles
it's
a dishwasher
like it was just very weird and when i
called her on it it was a huge [ __ ]
health crisis
and that happened like two or three
times she would like mid oh my heart
not to say she didn't have health
problems she when she got out here she
became diabetic she was not living she
wasn't really taking great care of
herself she got real heavy she got real
like
not
she's like i don't know she wasn't it
was becoming she was aging she was like
she's in her low 60s
she didn't have to be
like becoming elderly necessarily but
she's still so like
she just never got past my dad
and it was just it just kept really
getting worse i feel like
so when we moved to austin she moved to
texas too
but she moved like three hours away to
my aunt's house in houston now my aunt
is a nurse and like a psychological
doctor nurse she ran a hospital her
whole career she's successful
she's uh the mom of my two cousins i'm
talking about detroit got you the
computer and this whole [ __ ]
she's like three years older than my mom
you're closer to her than the other ants
yeah i guess
we're fine we've got no [ __ ] problems
no i'm saying like in terms of like oh i
see you way more than i talk to you way
more than i talk to them
we really just talk once barely once in
a while
but there's no it's just how it is i
just don't have a lot of contact with
them but there's no reason behind it
it's just how it is
so
uh
we my mom came and she came and visited
us like you know one time we were only
in texas for like [ __ ] three months
and we moved right back
your mom just said [ __ ] i'm moving to
texas too so yeah even though we told
her it wasn't about us moving to texas
she was gonna do it anyway because she
didn't want to work anymore which is
what i think it was she wanted to live
with my aunt my aunt has a nice house
she lives by herself
she wanted to i don't know i guess us
going to texas probably had something to
do with it but she was
after i told her like hey you're on this
waiting list
like
we're moving back you don't got to do
this she still did it she told me i made
the executive decision that me and your
aunt are just happier when we're hanging
out together and i'm going to stay down
here and that's fine that was [ __ ]
fine with me i'm like by all means live
your life if that's what you want to do
and
it was stressful having her around too
just
just this elephant in the [ __ ] room
became
like we didn't have a normal
relationship anymore it was always weird
she was always like i was always on edge
it was always just
i felt [ __ ] horrible about it too
like i felt really bad that i really
always said i feel like an [ __ ] but
god
he told me the same [ __ ] yeah i couldn't
because i couldn't bring it up to her
what the like like what type of [ __ ] is
this what if you did she faked the heart
actually yeah like and i i told april
when we first got together that that is
how it was and she didn't really
understand
until all this [ __ ] happened
so now
now she's down in texas and we move
right back to california
and
things start kind of taking off things
start
going well for me more so than they were
before i meet with you i'm
getting booked to do big video shoots
i'm starting to take [ __ ] to the next
level
so she came out to visit um
last year
yeah this exact time right around this
exact time last year
because i just got booked to film a
[ __ ] super bowl commercial
and it was a really really really big
deal
so
she came to visit and she was
going to see some of her old friends
from work and this is like [ __ ] pete
covett
so anytime i get booked for a shoot i
got to go test basically every day so
that means i got to drive up to la and
get tested
and drive back and i still got to get
tested like the next day
it's super high [ __ ] covet [ __ ] going
on
and this is the biggest opportunity in
my life by [ __ ] far i never imagined
i'd be filming on super bowl commercial
sets for t-mobile right this is with
goddamn gwen stefani and adam levine
blake shelton huge opportunity by far
the biggest opportunity i've ever been
involved in
and
as i'm going i'm making my whole day is
now going to lady gekko tested
as i'm going to get cold tested she's
going to go see some of her friends from
work and i go
oh cool i'm going to drive to la to get
kobe tested you got a mask
if you need any masks we got some right
here she's like no i'm good
remind you she has diabetes she's not in
great shape to begin with she's like out
of shape she's not some [ __ ] peak
athlete by any stretch
you have all your kids in the house all
the kids are in the house yeah i mean
so then she proceeds and i watch her she
walks out goes and gets in this [ __ ]
fool's car that looks like santa claus
he's got no mask on she's got no mask on
they got the windows up she gets in
closes the door and they take off
i'm like [ __ ] mind blown
that she would do that
and i assume it was just a mistake like
she forgot to put her mask on
uh
so then as i'm like coming back from l.a
i'm texting her like are you going to go
get like tested or
what's the plan here because i saw you
get in his car i was [ __ ] furious but
i was being really nice what's the plan
here because i saw you get in this car
without a mask on and i got my super
bowl shoots this week so i don't
understand like
and she's like we'll talk about it when
i get home and i'm like
okay but if you got [ __ ] covet that's
gonna be a problem yeah because not only
that she went and met with a bunch of
other [ __ ] friends inside somebody's
house and she told me that they were
going to hang out at some [ __ ] park
or some stupid [ __ ] i don't [ __ ] know
so then she starts getting real
defensive and she starts getting all
[ __ ] mind blown that i have the
audacity to like basically check her
about it when she does get home and i'm
i told april before she got there i'm
like
this is it
she's gonna be [ __ ] piss and leave
this is it like beyond that i don't i
i'm in a position now where i have to
[ __ ] say something i've spent all
this time just trying to avoid any real
life conversations with her
because i don't know where it'll [ __ ]
lead to
so
uh i check her on it and i don't back
down at all i check her on it like i
would anybody else how are you gonna go
off to this [ __ ] knowing what i got
going on here not to mention our kids in
this house and [ __ ] covid and she's
being an [ __ ] about it she's like
defending her like how dare you try to
tell me what to do it was an accident
[ __ ] that type of [ __ ] and then she
proceeds to
sit
without talking to me
for a full [ __ ] day in the house
before we're able to book her a [ __ ]
hotel room and take her to it so she can
she sat in the [ __ ] house for a whole
day and then had us take her to a hotel
for the rest of her trip because she was
so [ __ ] offended that i had the
audacity to [ __ ]
bring this [ __ ] up
frustrating bro i was really really
[ __ ] mad not to mention i'm in the
it's happening
all the [ __ ] i've set out for is [ __ ]
happening
and she keeps
with this [ __ ] [ __ ] every time
something big is gonna happen like i'm
gonna move here or i got like the night
that she did the [ __ ] with the let the
[ __ ] on fire
all right i work for fighter and the kid
sounds day one all right before day one
i was maybe i don't know
[ __ ] five six years into working with
these [ __ ] fools i had never hung out
with these [ __ ] fools at all like i
was we were on a remote basis they blew
up all this cool [ __ ] i was just deep
behind the scenes we were having our
christmas party that night
it was
that like
that [ __ ] night
and i called my aunt her other sister
and
and she was like i told her what
happened
like and me and her kind of reconnected
before i left like i said and so she
was kind of like
giving me some guidance around this [ __ ]
and she was just telling me how she's
like you know your gram sits here and
she'll just be like staring out the
window and be like
why doesn't zion even talk to me
oh she doesn't get it either and yeah
like she doesn't know she's just [ __ ]
wondering like she doesn't get she
doesn't get it i guess
and my aunt's like shh she's not just an
[ __ ]
when she said that
that she's like you got to live your
life right now
sometimes when people people gotta
[ __ ] sleep in the bed they've made
some times in life
when she said that [ __ ] i was like if it
just it gave me uh
like
changed my perspective
on i felt like i was being manipulated
of 100 i know you met your mom when i do
that
everything every time you're about to do
something cool that would make you go
further away from her
she did something [ __ ] up to you
or try to do some [ __ ] that would make
you like well maybe i shouldn't go maybe
i shouldn't leave it was just like she
just didn't that none of that was like i
don't know she wasn't thinking about
yeah she wasn't thinking about what i
had going on at all
uh so
then we moved back
she comes that all happens the kovich
[ __ ] happens and she just leaves now
we're not talking now after less than a
year ago now yeah
yeah so now from
say that was december you know january
february march april we're really not
talking and i was [ __ ] fine with it
to be honest we're just busy too i'm so
we're doing it like if you want to cut
me off for some [ __ ] you did
what the [ __ ] do you want me to do
there's already i already got all this
[ __ ] i'm walking around with and you're
thinking that the way you're thinking is
like [ __ ] i'm such a piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] for thinking like this yes
constantly ever [ __ ] feel that way if
you need to cut somebody off to the
camera to you guys
[ __ ] them
that's it that's how you have to live
your life or you're going to live your
life for other people
well you you start in this situation
then you start living it for your kids
to have good grandparents because i
didn't have
i really didn't have grandparents
growing up yeah of course on either side
really
uh
you know so it's super important to
april and me that my kids have a [ __ ]
grandmother so like we didn't do what
she did i didn't go and get all butthurt
like she just started like talking to
april and but she also like wouldn't let
my daughter come down and visit her she
also really wasn't i don't know
she said no i wanted to come down yeah
like hey do you want an arianna to come
down and visit no well i'll just come
i'll come up there like she was just
starting to
not care about being in the kids lives
all like that
when she went back down there that was
leading up until yeah so december to
april so she's still not talking she's
living with my aunt my aunt and i knew
this was going to happen i predicted
this was going to happen my aunt went
out of town she was i'm assuming my mom
was butthurt over something and moved
out without telling her and got her own
apartment
out after moving over there yes
yeah
there was really no plan like she
literally went down there and she was
her job was to drive
drive kids to school
as if she doesn't have like
grandkids we don't have school buses
so she went and that now she's moved out
of my aunt's house and she moved into an
apartment that is the same amount she
was paying to live in [ __ ] santa ana
not to mention would be the same amount
you'd be paying to live on the [ __ ]
ocean and san clemente
so whatever still
fine
but not very cool to my aunt you move
out without telling her over god knows
what so now anyway she goes out she has
her own apartment
fine
um
but she's starting to like tell my aunt
and my cousins down there like she's
starting to act very like depressed and
she's blaming it on me and like my
daughter basically she's be like being
my aunt said she's like being nasty to
my cousins down there just kind of being
a dick across the board
but she's like blaming it on like it's
my fault when in reality she's the one
not talking to me over some [ __ ] she did
this is all during season one yeah all
that's been going on behind the [ __ ]
scene yeah
so
i didn't give a [ __ ]
at that i'm like i know what it is and
she texted me kind of trying to
instigate some [ __ ] and i left it like
i don't know what your point is with
this text if you're not trying to
instigate some [ __ ]
i
accept that we don't i said we don't
exist in the same reality
so i can't move past this without you
like acknowledging it but i also accept
that we don't exist in the same reality
so that's just where we are because i
can't let this [ __ ] go
who the [ __ ] would i be just let's not
like all i'm looking for is just like
it's just i'm not i don't want an
apology just like
maybe an apology would be nice some
accountability of like i'm sorry i
basically tried to [ __ ] you over and
then
then blamed you for it afterwards to
everybody else like just not even then
it started then so she started it
started i started to hear about like
that
and then
here's the [ __ ] kicker then she
started to get really weird
ailments that really couldn't like the
the next call i got was hey she was
trying to clean some [ __ ] off her fridge
and she fell and like her knees are
bruised up she's gonna she's gotta go to
the hospital her knees are all [ __ ] up
okay she's still not talking to me okay
cool we're still hearing about this [ __ ]
and then literally from there it started
[ __ ] spiraling this is around august
yeah yeah
this is this is july august oh [ __ ]
we're getting to your oh [ __ ] we're
getting to august right now so
oh
yeah so um
she
started like with a series of like
ailments
and i think a lot of it was probably a
lot of it was like with her stomach she
had diabetes she didn't really eat
healthy
she didn't like take care of herself and
she started having all these like issues
and then she was like
like
not taking care of herself and then
she's just back to living at my aunt's
house
and i didn't i didn't really have a
sense of what was really going on
because she's hearing it through your
hand what i am hearing i'm hearing
through my aunt me and her don't really
talk all like that to begin with but
then i get a call on my birthday
that she was unresponsive and they found
a bunch of pills next to my aunt's bed
and that when the [ __ ]
ambulance came she started [ __ ]
freaking out and [ __ ] was like [ __ ]
screaming at my cousins and why the [ __ ]
did you wake me up
all this [ __ ]
and then they took her to the hospital
and then now
i was like all right once i found that
out i was like all this [ __ ] is out the
window we're not like i said we started
talking
and
we had like a regular like a normal she
was acting on normal i didn't come out
and ask her i don't think like if that
like what
what what the [ __ ] was going on but she
made it seem like
it wasn't that she made it seem like
it wasn't that big of a deal that she
tried to die
i when i talked to her like she made it
seem like oh yeah i tried it was like
she didn't she didn't know i knew all
those details
mind you my aunt is a [ __ ]
her career is running a hospital a
psychiatric word of a hospital if
there's anybody more qualified patient
in her house to be helping her it's her
so
what'd your answer
my aunt thought it was very [ __ ]
suspicious
what was suspicious the whole scenario
and not just how she was acting and like
she's faked didn't know the pills no no
i don't think she faked it but she
thought she thought that it was she
thought that that's what it was she
thought that she was trying to end it
but
but
what i found out afterwards is right
before that her she had found out that
her [ __ ] social security was about to
run up or something oh this is right
that's what it was and i think maybe
just coincidentally it was my birthday
but that like was i don't know i don't
know but i woke up from a nap on my
birthday to that
and
and that that [ __ ] was [ __ ] crazy
and then um then we started talking
again and
she was like
saying how she's focusing on should
focus on getting better and she was like
she went through a couple stints ago and
like random symptoms that they didn't
really know what the [ __ ] was going on
like the last thing she texted me was
my heart checked out clear
i i got a full check my heart said clear
so
you know that was when that was like a
couple days ago
okay so from from your birthday to now
to a couple days ago you're still
talking frequently again
yeah okay okay yeah i got once i
realized that she wasn't well we started
like
yeah talking and all that you know
because she was like what i think
happened
she had kovit when she left
she had my aunt told me she i don't know
but she [ __ ] had it
and if you get a coveted shot she got
vaccinated after she had it and me and
april read online that
if you have like too many antibodies
from having it and then you get the
vaccine that there's all these symptoms
that can [ __ ] happen but she she had
pre-existing pre-existing because she
had other [ __ ] going on diabetic and all
this other [ __ ]
but we told my aunt and her like guys
the doctors literally aren't
being able to figure out why you're
having all these stomach problems and
your legs are getting out on you and
you're like having all these issues but
it looks like right here these symptoms
are in line with what this we sent him
the article i brought it up to him like
[ __ ] four times five times like is
anybody checking on this
and she was like she basically told me
yeah yeah like they're you know they
know what they're doing basically
they're you know looking into whatever
but
so
you guys are having a regular
conversation you guys were actually
talking mm-hmm a couple until a couple
days ago yeah april face time with her
like [ __ ] two days ago
what the [ __ ] yeah with the kids and
[ __ ]
and she was saying that she like she was
going to like uh
rehab cause the past couple months she
was in and out for being mentally kind
of [ __ ] both i mean it started with oh
i'm so depressed but then it like
it snowballed into like there's these a
bunch of random physical symptoms going
on that the doctors can't figure out
what's going on
but also at the same time
i got the sense from my aunt
who was with her like every day that
she's sick there's something going on
but at the same time
i feel like
she could be like doing more or
something like not to say that she was
not sick
but my aunt felt was starting to feel a
little bit like she was being taken
advantage of
two calls ago i got that from her
and when she said that i was like [ __ ]
man like
i
i really thought that she was gonna live
another [ __ ] 30 years and it was
gonna be just some like she was either i
don't i knew she didn't want to work i
thought she was going to live with my
aunt or she was going to come i didn't
want her to come and live with us
just because i didn't want that like i
wanted her to come and live by us again
but i didn't i'm not able to [ __ ]
support her
especially now like
we just spent all our money on a house
the house is still under construction we
don't have any extra money
for all all this [ __ ] at all
and let alone like you know
i just wanted her to have her own life
again and because we were getting the
sense that she had just like checked out
basically
she wasn't talking to the
to the grandkids really
she had
checked out just in a lot of ways
and this was
a few days ago that
your aunt found a letter
no my aunt told me yesterday
yesterday
she wrote this letter back in september
she wrote it on
her my dad's anniversary september 20th
she started having all these issues
somewhere around then august
but she was talking about the letter's
called my final thoughts oh god
it's not a suicide letter but it's a
letter about
your final thoughts at the end of life
back in september she was not that
[ __ ] sick
it was all centered around her falling
from the fridge and her knees and the
bruising and like something going on
they cleared her heart
but
and i don't know what's going to happen
from this but my aunt told me that like
they had moved her from the hospital to
like uh like a rehab style place to get
her like back up and walking and [ __ ]
and we had offered the whole time like
do you want us to come down there do you
want to like can do you want to come
back up here tell me i think i'm going
to texas this weekend
no yeah like later no
and then they moved they sent her to
like a rehab
and my aunt was with her this is two
nights ago
and my aunt like at at night before she
had to leave or whatever was calling the
doc the doctor was supposed to like come
and check her out and evaluate her that
day she was like waiting for her to come
all day she never came
at like six o'clock my aunt calls her
and the doctor tells her i'm not
actually gonna be coming today we'll
check her out in the morning
but my aunt
noticed something was wrong with my mom
was like she's not doing well she's not
really responsive
she's not
something's wrong you guys really need
to see her tonight
and the ladies like what will
she'll be okay overnight we'll check her
out in the morning
mind you i don't know what the [ __ ] they
were thinking
if they were like
her symptoms aren't that serious
or if they were just being [ __ ] lazy
about it
but
five in the morning rolls around and she
went into like cardiac arrest or some
[ __ ] and they called my aunt back
and then right when my aunt got there
she died
at this rehab
i don't i think you i think they rushed
her back over these places are [ __ ]
next door to each other i think oh god
they put her back in the hospital
and uh
yeah man i really didn't think that [ __ ]
was going to happen
no of course not bro it's like
all the [ __ ] we've been talking about
lately too
all the [ __ ] uh about talking
literally talking about your mom we're
just talking yeah i mean i've been kind
of like
days ago yeah
i've been keeping you loosely kind of
just because i thought there was a bunch
of times i thought i was gonna have to
go to texas well you told me like every
three weeks i think i might have to text
this week all right well
let's make sure we [ __ ] buckle down
yeah we're going to work out the way and
they kept being like no it's not that
serious if i like it so you keep saying
well they said she's all right and she
doesn't want me to come so
yeah and my aunt also said if it were to
be if it were to get um would you need a
joint
appreciate you
my aunt's like listen if it were to be
that serious i would not let something
happen to your mom without having you
down here i'll let you know if you
really need to come down here
so it's not like she knew it was just
kind of an unexpected it was a freak it
was
i mean they just evaluated her heart and
somehow she went into [ __ ] cardiac
arrest
so i called the medical examiner
yesterday and asked them to do a [ __ ]
autopsy and they were like talk to me
like i was [ __ ] stupid
wait
because i was like this this doesn't
make sense
they just cleared her heart and now she
has a heart attack two days later
she has a history of self
harm almost
can we [ __ ] see if something like
something else happened is there
anything in her blood did she [ __ ] with
some of her [ __ ] did somebody else [ __ ]
with her [ __ ] oh i see what you're
saying
how's she gonna be cleared for her heart
and then have a [ __ ] heart attack
granted i'm no goddamn doctor
but
she was like well did she have access to
her medicine i'm like i'm not there i'm
in california i don't i don't know my
i'm like my aunt's there she's a nurse i
don't
i don't think she like oh deed i don't
know
how you can [ __ ] with your equipment
i don't i don't even know i have i'm
just like can you check if something's
weird and they were like unless you have
evidence of a suicide or a homicide
like they ruled it that we don't need to
check it she had all these issues here
that could be the cause of this
so they won't check
yeah the movies really lie to us bro i
thought you get an autopsy no matter
what so my aunt is having her attorney
look into the show tomorrow
you're gonna go down there thursday
i don't know
not sure yet i don't know what's gonna
happen
[ __ ] would you get a barry back in
buffalo would you guys well she wrote
she wrote this letter
yes get out get on the letter my final
thoughts she basically
talked about her entire life
yeah it's a three-page letter typed up
and it was like picked up yeah that was
the weird part i don't i don't yeah it
was it was a picture of it but it was
printed out on paper three pages
and she just talked about like uh
she opened up the letter talking about
her grandmother
and how she learned to be a good
grandmother from her grandmother
and then she talked about how she didn't
have a happy childhood and she wasn't
close to her family
but then she like it was like a summary
of her life and then like i got a
paragraph and april got a paragraph and
my kids got a paragraph
and then she was talking about knowing
that there's an afterlife and
not being attached to her life or her
body
and
that people will say when she dies that
at least she's with charlie now and that
they're right
not
charge your dad for everyone yeah
and that she like knew she was gonna be
you know
greeted by whoever whatever and that she
was just at peace with it or whatever
so
it was just so much different than when
my dad died
yeah like it was such a drew like drawn
out thing and this was so we've talked
about it
the fact that this is happening right
now is crazy bro
yeah
and i definitely could have i definitely
could have did more
we talked about this before i was
[ __ ] mad though not even that you're
mad you have three [ __ ] kids a
full-time career
you made every [ __ ] offer and effort
to go hey come out here hey can i go out
there hey not much what you can do than
just show up and then get in a fight
because she's like why the [ __ ] you're
here i was really worried about that
because
ultimately i know that we can't move on
in our relationship until some of these
questions are answered and i know that i
can't ask them
and i also want to be like you really
took this [ __ ] with your mother
literally to the [ __ ] grave
you got this old lady sitting here the
past three years not really
understanding what the [ __ ] is going on
i don't know what she said to her
at the funeral but she said something
and that was it
and it's like
just how she spun the [ __ ] around it
really had me at the end like you she
isolated you pretty much yeah and then
just to not even really acknowledge or
recognize it
i mean
you know
april's family is big and they're
connected and like
they do [ __ ] they go places they do
things they do things with kids
they're a real family yeah they have
fights and then they are still family
you know it was just it was just nothing
like that and she just never really
acknowledged that she never
we never even [ __ ] talked about it
like
when i before i moved to california i
went up to my aunt's factory and like i
[ __ ] met with her for like the first
time she was [ __ ] bawling
and i asked her like is this true about
my grandfather and shouldn't like i
never even got a straight real answer
out of her really
she was just like
i don't doubt that it's true but
none of
nobody else let it ruin
let it trickle so hard so [ __ ] far
it's not that much fault though no not
at all i mean she didn't even have a
fair shot like this [ __ ] no i don't know
what she went through but i know as you
look at her pictures of her eyes as a
little kid and [ __ ] she looks [ __ ]
like
like
pissed
and i know she was always getting in
trouble as kid i'm sure she was on
drugs and like not she wasn't like an
addict but i'm sure she was deep in the
hippie [ __ ]
i mean where's you where's your mom's
family from
buffalo oh for real but she met your dad
in la though no
well i don't no no they met in buffalo
okay they they like they like lived
around the country separately like they
both lived around the country randomly
my dad used to live in compton really he
taught chess at a park in compton
i don't even know if compton was compton
then but i always thought that [ __ ] was
funny because he's just the whitest dude
of all time
teaching chance at a park
back when that was a job yeah
probably on some i don't know but yeah
then they came back to buffalo and
she met like
gigging out like like you said he's the
musician she's the hippie girl and
that's that's how it went and they were
they had that was their life they were
[ __ ]
you know they were totally [ __ ] my
dad had no ambitions of like
striking it big or just playing music
they were just playing music he had us
they were small business owners she ran
you know i used to do i used to enter in
all the receipts for all his
you talking talking about the talk oh
the the lessons yeah
sorry one second my bad
sorry
uh
so he talked guitar used to do receipts
um
this is such an odd episode yeah i just
i mean i'm talking about in the terms of
like
it's just so final i feel
you know
i always wanted to talk about this [ __ ]
but i never thought i would really be
able to just to get it off my chest she
would freak out and do something crazy
in a meaningful way that might help out
a lot of kids out there
we wanted to talk about this because it
will help out because there's gonna be
hundreds of people going
holy [ __ ] that sounds just like me
because you thought your mom would
[ __ ] kill herself she heard this [ __ ]
i would never have spoken about that
i even talked about it many times like
she might kill herself like no it's
really like a not stable situation i was
very [ __ ] careful to never talk about
anything
that i didn't you know i just i didn't
want to make i didn't ever want to make
her feel bad but at the same time it's
like part of my story
it is my story and i have to explain
this [ __ ] to my kids
and i don't want to explain this [ __ ] to
my kids and i'm not going to because
when you get older play this episode
like this is what the [ __ ] i grew up
with done
never thought about that yeah that's it
i didn't want to let that pain keep
trickling
but at the same time it's like they
didn't grow up around my family at all
when you call me on facetime and go
kids don't kids grow up bad right tell
them thomas they got it good right
and like yeah i'm like you guys live in
the bomb house and both your parents are
here and they don't beat the [ __ ] out of
you and everything's cool you guys are
doing great you got a nice bad damn
night yeah yeah
no [ __ ] night these people will call
me out of nowhere tell my [ __ ] kids
that they got it so damn good yeah
yeah guys it's
your dad's cool
but i think the point is the points
about resentment
the points about elephants in the room
the points about
my advice would be to be
strong enough to
to not be burdened by that
even
i don't know i don't know i mean i would
hold if i i don't know i don't know what
i would do i don't know how if i were
her like
you know it just it seems it it was just
not
like consistent too like she would kind
of all my family wanted to do was be
back in with our table like my aunt like
she would oh like it was on her mind i
could tell she cut your grandma off but
cut all her sisters and brothers off too
yeah but then she would let them in a
little bit as i got a little bit older
she started talking to her sisters and
her brother again but then like she got
herself all wrapped up in
my uncle's divorce so much so that i'm
pretty sure he had to call the [ __ ]
cops on her because
she got so wrapped up in it that she was
like
doing crazy harassment [ __ ]
i heard
whoa your mom goes hard
but under the guise of a [ __ ] healer
that was what really bothered me like
her whole thing was that she was
dancing above you have very you have
good patience
i would have lost my [ __ ] at 12. i would
have she wasn't like that already she
wasn't like that at all yeah sorry
that's the weird thing about it i never
had these thoughts at all until i was
like 1920 where i started and then the
[ __ ] with jamelle happened and that was
like literally slow motion i still
[ __ ] see it
her like it was so just
seinfeld white trash moment
in uh in our driveway
jerry springer
yeah yeah it was one of those and i was
just like i felt so betrayed
and uh there's a duke
he called me yesterday for the first
time yeah so i don't know if you want to
bring that up yeah i didn't answer the
first time you he called you reached out
since you moved away
right yeah
yeah
i didn't i didn't talk to anybody except
for you i didn't really [ __ ] feel
like talking like no it's not the
goddamn time
i understand i wanted to talk to you
guys
this is different though yeah um thank
you by the way like all the
messages and comments and stuff were
really awesome
i don't like i really really really
don't like the type of energy
or attention of
everybody knowing that something bad
just happened to you
i i got that attention a lot
and i don't like it
but
you can't have a show and not talk about
your life
of course
and now that you can freely kind of
freely talk about because there's so
much bro you told me i would rant i
found myself kind of ranting at you
because because you've never talked
about it april's there for all the [ __ ]
yeah you've never talked about it before
we talked like [ __ ] three hours
yesterday
yeah you've never been able to talk
about this [ __ ]
for fear of of just walking on eggshells
yeah i'm so friendly just negative not
wanting to not want to hurt her feelings
i don't know if that was the right thing
evidently that was not the right [ __ ]
thing to do
i don't know because literally this
spiral occurred after i was like
here we go i literally before i had to
check her over the kovid [ __ ] i told
april
here we go i don't know where this is
going to end
but that's you that's
if not then you like i said you can't
live your life for other [ __ ]
dude there's so many people out there
that that just resonated hard because i
know they're doing that right now
tiptoeing around your [ __ ] parents
because you don't want to [ __ ] quit
college even though you don't want to be
in [ __ ] school
talk about the [ __ ]
you have to
you truly have to but for you as a i'm
told you cannot talk about certain [ __ ]
because your mom
and
you don't want to
this isn't worth her doing some crazy
[ __ ] yeah you know that's why we never
talked about any of your stuff like that
yeah so i think that's the takeaway it's
just gonna make me
i'm just trying to like what is the big
what can we learn
can we learn from this i know it's it's
super [ __ ] up because it's your mom
and [ __ ] but i know
for me looking at an outside perspective
i can always say this is a movie
what's the outcome
it's only up bro and i'm not saying your
mom was holding you back
your mom was holding you back
in terms of you can't even live your
full life without being like oh
oh [ __ ] can i do that is she gonna
[ __ ] lose it go to a [ __ ]
psychiatric ward kill herself and take
you're going through this [ __ ] for
months bro for months
you called me like you're on collision
for a long time
it's not that this is better at all and
then you shay we should perform a [ __ ]
though you much rather have her living
here being your [ __ ] grandma but she
did that
where i find peace in it all is i know
she didn't really want that yeah she
didn't care she was like i'm fine with
just being here i knew it even like back
when we lived in buffalo like she's
after he died
she's done
she just didn't she couldn't find
in her letters mom ever date another
person no [ __ ] no there it is your mom
was so even before him i don't even know
i have not like their lives before me
are a [ __ ] mystery in a lot of ways i
don't i don't i don't know your mom was
just obsessed with him bro she was just
that was her that was her whole identity
and she never was able to bounce back
she mentioned in her letter not being
remembered for like being taken down by
grief
but
i think i mean that real if he was still
alive she would still be alive
if she would have gone first
i don't think he would he wouldn't know
ten years later he
he would have been back to himself he
would have his own life for sure
your dad seemed like a very uh
he does music but he seems like a
[ __ ] mechanic i was gonna do my job
come home he was a food right okay
you did good you crashed the car [ __ ]
yeah yeah that's how i feel like you're
dead very simple
to himself yeah no no opinion yeah just
couldn't be better
both like
couldn't be better at mining his own
business couldn't be better at just
being like
just chilling
wasn't he didn't have he didn't have all
this extra energy and i think probably
maybe even
he if he were alive
and i were to like talk to him about all
this [ __ ] i think he would like
get it he would understand
he would it'd be cool to be able to
relate to him about all this [ __ ]
but um
yeah man it's it's cool to be able to
talk about it like this it's been a long
[ __ ] time
your whole life
weird you've been one day being able to
freely talk
yeah
[ __ ] even freely think sometimes just
just get it all out because i just i
don't ever want to feel act like or feel
like i'm throwing people under the bus
with [ __ ] but it's like
if it's my life if
if you're in my life to the point that
you you've defined chapters in my life
i'm allowed to talk about the show
exactly
if you're in the book there's a reason
or like her if you have a chapter
or a paragraph
i find it wild that she did her final
thought summary a couple months ago
you know that's kind of her i don't want
to say her style but
uh
it was her style to to
to like
to act like she knew so much about the
afterlife that she was be fine with
writing these are my final thoughts
but she wasn't even that sick then
or like i don't know exactly he was sick
those were still the early stages of
like
i hurt my knees
i'm depressed
i don't know she didn't really ever talk
to me she didn't she would always have
like elaine that's okay here we go it's
another big [ __ ] thing she never
really had friends like she would get
friends from like the internet that uh
we're into the metaphysical [ __ ] too
elaine was like that too but she was
local and your mom cut elaine off over
an argument i didn't even know that when
we when we moved to texas and she came
to visit us at one time she very [ __ ]
casually was like elaine died
we're like what she's like
she said it's so nonchalant she's my
best friend she died she died she and
then she goes she was ready
that's what you said i know i know
you've been through this so much but i
kind of gotta be honest bro your mom
might have been on some [ __ ]
maybe they were tapped into some [ __ ]
maybe i mean you never know she elaine
committed suicide
so
take it all back
that's what she meant by she was ready
i'll take this all back
i thought
i thought no
so and the way you elaine committed
suicide just uh
clear that up she was ready
of course she did it
that was your mom's answer to that
it hit me in the chest when you said
that [ __ ]
me and april both looked she was so
[ __ ] just like maybe she was there to
assist
real best friendship like you you're
done i'll be there i'll help you nah she
was she was on some [ __ ] like that dude
people are wild that's crazy that's your
mom
so
like she mentioned one of her friends in
her letter that i never heard of
she would like get friends she'd like
and then she'd act like it was normal
like oh so-and-so from [ __ ] russia's
in town and so and so from south africa
because they all do the metaphysical
crazy energy [ __ ]
wow your mom was part of that community
she considered herself that like but at
the same time
who the [ __ ] are we healing here
that was my thing like heal something
then my dad just
went was tortured for eight years you're
going through all this [ __ ] you're
inadvertently putting everybody else
throw all this [ __ ] with you like
let's get some [ __ ] healing going at
some point was the other thing too you
can't can't sit here act like patience
you have such patience i don't lost my
[ __ ]
act like you're like you know what's
gonna happen you know this [ __ ] is all
you're a [ __ ] psychic but all this
horrible [ __ ] is happening and give me a
[ __ ] heads up then how about
totally funny thing to take away give me
a [ __ ] heads up
like i always say when i see these
little psychic
buildings off the freeway you guys know
what i'm talking about
why even have the building and pay the
rent if you're a psychic just find your
clients
you're a cycle there's a couple holes in
that business model but they're they're
in business though they shouldn't ask
you your name when you walk in yeah
what's your name shouldn't you [ __ ]
know
me
tell me
exactly
wow wow so you grew up in uh all right
all right i didn't realize your mom was
so heavy into the spiritual [ __ ]
yeah so that's the nine perfect
strangers when i told you to watch it
yeah i watched it like that yeah she's
like that lady
trying to remember i'm trying to blank
on that [ __ ] show but
oh yeah yeah now i remember she walks
around she thought of herself like that
lady that's what i'm saying yes
wow
she did trying to talk to the dead like
you just said that's what the whole show
is about yeah but it yeah yeah it was
like uh it's an interesting thing it's
like an ego like a
it's like it's like a defense
it's a defense it's in its ego sitting
on top of a defense mechanism
way to put it because
if she didn't have all that belief and
faith in
her [ __ ] then
it would have been too much to deal with
i guess
but i didn't like that she got me
thinking like that for a stretch when my
dad was real sick like um
like why did why did why did this happen
like
what am i doing wrong that this would
happen type of [ __ ] basically or like
there's there's some outside force off
there you know that's
causing this [ __ ] to happen like she got
me thinking like her for a [ __ ] while
i thought like her i realized i was very
much like her
because i would cut them like we were
talking about cut people out of my life
immediately i was super cold
and i realized like
that i got that from her
yeah and i had that but if it's a
provide
you're logical though no i'm not like
that
i don't hold vengeances and [ __ ] no i've
i'm trying to learn from her for that
like it left her
at the end of the day alone
she didn't have any real friends or
family because she had isolated herself
from everybody
she was with my aunt my aunt i don't
want to like the situation
enabled my mom to
[Music]
not have to work
or but but still she just
took it like
to another level i feel bad that that
happened to my aunt
she went down there
to live with her my aunt was like yeah
hey we're both
getting a little older we're single like
you know i i could see uh and in one
sense i'm like this could be [ __ ]
awesome for you
thank you for being here
yeah it could be great let's get you uh
let's get something going let's get some
life going like if you don't want it to
be your grandkids
okay get a small time job we'll work at
the [ __ ] public library something
yeah old ladies that are widows we see
them all the time they figure it out
they keep pushing forward with life
but
that's sad
i feel bad for your mom honestly yeah me
too i feel i feel really bad on a lot of
different levels
it's like the villain like what caused
the villain kind of thing not that
saying she's a bad person yeah saying
what caused like the bad [ __ ] to spark
she just needed therapy we want uh we
went to
we went to therapy the other day to try
it out we took we took my daughter to
our counselor just let her talk some
things out we've been having some issues
and [ __ ]
i should have been in there my whole
life like not to think it was some
magical experience but
that
is the problem
because we never talked about anything
that was just i think a lot of families
are like that like probably we didn't
talk about how bad my dad was suffering
we didn't talk about it was too much
like it was too much to [ __ ] talk
about literally we didn't talk about how
bad she was suffering we were talking
when she was strung out on pills we
didn't talk about when she was probably
suicidal in buffalo
we didn't talk about
[ __ ] anything
you know but me and her used to talk
about everything something
changed something changed when he got
sick
like polar opposites changed
and i don't know if it was just that i
became an adult and i started
interfacing with her as an adult instead
of a kid
or if
something snapped and changed during all
that pain
but whatever it was
she really wasn't able to bounce back
from it
i don't feel like and unfortunately i
feel like that's the truth
well damn
so
yeah that summed up pretty well
i'm glad you had to talk about it though
i feel better it was a goddamn whirlwind
of thoughts on my head like ever since
ever since yesterday when it started
she called me my aunt was crying
she told me
just
just a tornado of [ __ ] thoughts
right up until now
yeah
guys when you told me like let's do the
[ __ ] episode
well we i don't want to ruin it but we
have a huge guest book for tuesday
and monday and tuesday bro yeah
right tomorrow well
today's sunday today's sunday i gotta
look at the calendar we have a yeah we
have a really well today it's tomorrow
oh [ __ ] okay it's tomorrow tomorrow at
six o'clock yeah it is time and then we
talked about dr drew yeah dr drew was
booked but tuesday night he might
reschedule because we he he would have
had a heart out after like an hour yeah
like an hour we don't want we need to
wait
i was going to talk to dr drew about
this [ __ ] well not even that we booked
doctor drew before this because your mom
was driving you [ __ ] insane i was i
had this happened
maybe we should just have [ __ ] dr dre
even if it is a [ __ ] hour come in bro
i mean maybe it's fine now i was going
to ask his advice like what should i do
i was going to pull him aside afterwards
like i hope you got another [ __ ] hour
in your bro cause i need some real life
[ __ ] advice cause i don't know how to
handle this situation
but anyway we were gonna do the april
episode which was still going to be an
amazing episode but it's gonna happen we
couldn't not do this and i didn't want
to not have an episode for this week to
come out so i don't know when it's gonna
come out but we'll have an episode for
this week
and just all the support from the fans
yesterday i was thinking about it all
day and there was no way we could have
did it yesterday but i just
no april was like
you should go do it
yeah do something it helps
the [ __ ] the deal with death episode
that should help me so [ __ ] much yeah
even though this is fresh as [ __ ] and
all the people in the comments that were
impacted by that episode oh yeah that
was different
yeah so that was [ __ ] different
but that was very similar and you were
dealing with that behind the scenes and
then it just comes to a head and you
have to address it and [ __ ] this you're
doing the same exact thing
dealing with the same [ __ ]
yeah except i feel way worse because the
person i talked about was one of my best
homies yeah
you're just saying you're struggling
through life because of it
yeah i'm you know i'm sorry that her
story ended like that
when i was a kid i would have never
imagined
like this is how
like the story of your life is going to
end
weird
but
it's in your hands though
you can have it i mean she had it on
track for [ __ ] a long time they had
me when they were like 35 40 or whatever
right up until i was a teenager i mean
they did it they had a successful house
they were [ __ ] happy
it was fine
but just because it doesn't mean it's
going to be like that forever you got to
keep
like
evolving to keep your life going yeah no
matter how old you are
honestly i can't wait till i'm [ __ ]
85 yeah
i know i mean hopefully yeah i mean like
you want ideally your goal is to be
[ __ ] comfortable and to have your
kids uh [ __ ] all taken care of at that
point and just
mission accomplished that's the goal
exactly
but life is
so can be just so hard on you that like
grief
alone can take you out apparently
you know i don't know i don't know how
people go through [ __ ] they go through
losing kids
losing you know like
i get it
for sure
how easy it would be to check out
but
just when you're older in life and you
have grandkids and [ __ ]
it's ideal for that not to happen
but to each his own and
we all got we can't
like
take too much responsibility for
somebody else's path
that's the main thing in this episode
like the main thing to leave with is
you're still
so [ __ ] young that
this is going to be 30 years ago don't
remember 30 years ago my life was just
[ __ ] going wild
you mean like this is a different
chapter of your life towards not just
always focusing on like i can't do this
or that because of another person and
i'm like again i'm not trying to say it
isn't like
a good this is not a good thing at all
it would be a good thing to change your
ways the way she was going you guys were
talking again maybe move back
you watch the [ __ ] kids you have
another granddaughter that was cool as
[ __ ] yeah you know so
she didn't get to see the house that's a
bummer
but she also never even brought it up
really
i don't know she just wasn't that wasn't
on her mind
it's not even like
i i think
at a certain point you get so consumed
if you're in depression or if you're in
grief or if you're just kind of
checking out of wanting to be alive
it's selfish for other people to be like
damn you're not even thinking about me
yeah
i understand that
but i just wish that's so selfish as
[ __ ] to be like only me my problems
revolve around you
people don't realize when they [ __ ] up
and get all depressed or die or kill
themselves and [ __ ] it's like you [ __ ]
up so many other people's lives you
[ __ ]
more selfish to do that [ __ ] i felt so
bad putting this pain on my kids last
night
i was seven when my grandfather died up
until i found out he wasn't a good
person i thought he was a good person
yeah so i have a seven-year-old boy we
had to put that paint on him last night
bro you're gonna walk around with us
forever i'm sorry i gotta put this on
you
my
three-year-old doesn't understand what
the [ __ ] going on but she does
somewhat i mean and she like i said she
was a great grandmother like ariana
ariana was in her house in lackawanna
for the first five years of her life she
grew up there my dad lived long he
wasn't supposed to live long enough to
even see her he lived until she was like
two
like she was
ariana was in the house that i grew up
in lackawanna like with my mom a lot
when we'd go to work she was there it
was right there
we lived right she had a [ __ ] fool on
grandma yeah
full full on [ __ ] grandma full blown
and then even when she moved to
california you know like
i pat her on the back i said i'm gonna
make it happen she said i know you are
we took off into the [ __ ] distance
a year later we made it happen to the
point that she was able to move out
and she was fine doing that
but i just wish she'd never moved to
texas man i wish we never moved his head
i don't i think i don't need you can't
go back and
but that's the path the path that she
was on here she could have rolled that
out and it could have been [ __ ] cool
until you're 60.
yeah i mean she could have been yeah so
but you can't think about what could
have
maybe she was ready to go bro that's
what it sounded like it just sounded
like
it sounded like
not only am i like i'm okay if i go but
like she said in her letter i'm not
attached to my life or my body
she considered herself such
a [ __ ] spiritual realm person yeah
that she felt
more comfortable there than here
basically well honestly maybe that's not
even a bad thing for them
if she wasn't
there's probably
i feel like i discredit a lot of her
[ __ ]
without giving it a chance because
like she's been so like loopy about it
yeah
that of course
it hits a wall with me where i'm annoyed
as soon as i start hearing the [ __ ] yep
i totally and then remember i was just
talking about this the other day maybe
my mom weren't cool and we weren't
[ __ ] friends instead of sit through
it like
this is you and this is how it's gonna
be oh okay oh and i leave
yeah oh there's i wanted to yell eight
times [ __ ] yeah she's gonna do it so
long yeah that's that's exactly
and i felt so bad about that yeah
because you're like sorry april i'm
screaming in the [ __ ] steering wheel
to drive home i get it and then yeah
then when
and you have kids
you can't be like your grandma [ __ ]
sucks yeah you can't say that she went
on a vendetta against april i kind of
forgot about it in that part of the
story but
when that [ __ ] happened with jamel
she really did go on a [ __ ] vendetta
against april over really literally over
nothing just because
in the mix of that she
she started being real [ __ ] nasty
and despite that
april was always the person that was
there for her and understanding and
never took that [ __ ] to heart even
though they really [ __ ] ruined her
life for about
a couple months
and just putting a bunch of untrue [ __ ]
up in the air and just acting all
butthurt that i was starting a [ __ ]
family basically
and uh
and everybody's cool man they yeah like
you know they they were all [ __ ] even
though they're your parents not
everybody's
the greatest person that
not everybody's your f you want to hang
out with yeah that was the thing i
always wanted to be able to like yeah
like april and her mom have tons of
issues they still hang out and she's
still cool you still have a normal
conversation with her i was always like
i wish
that was the case
but like what always i was always like
what the [ __ ] too is that like
she cuts off everybody in life right
the one person she kept
contact with the whole time was jamelle
oh really
in his day
i think so oh is that why he called he
still yeah like and i'm like oh
we even when we were at like
we were at horrible odds over nothing
even at that moment she was playing both
sides of the fence she was which i get
but like your sons bro yeah i get it but
she gets it [ __ ] serious yeah i get
it and then she then like in granite
we've been at odds over nothing i've
there's nothing so like it's i was only
mad at like his like actions in that
time
but even then years go on and she'll
just start bringing it up oh you got
this going on i'm like what makes you
think i give a [ __ ] do i ask about this
[ __ ] why would you cut everybody off the
one dude who i'm had [ __ ]
this
horrible thing you don't want to be like
that too i don't want i don't want this
dude in my life like
keep [ __ ] bringing this [ __ ] up okay
and i'm gonna ignore it again
just just another thing like
you know that that was just weird but
she i mean she loved him i get it we
grew up like brothers she called him her
son yeah that's what i'm saying that was
that you always say my brother
yeah you never always say
my brother yeah always say that still
she yeah it's [ __ ] weird now
yeah took this
to get a call but i mean
not a can of worms i feel like [ __ ]
opening all right now you're busy bro
holidays this point in my life [ __ ]
you're going through
when you're ready you can only have that
call too
whatever he's watching this [ __ ] yeah
not it's not a bad thing no i understand
how you feel i'm just i'm so lucky to be
at this point in my life like this is
happening while i'm
realizing everything i've ever wanted
also
we're moving into the house we're
renovating the house we have the show
i've dropped my clients we're launching
all this [ __ ] yeah filming on big sets
wait
sorry we have to
the merch drops today
we never even talked about it
you know what i'm saying that's how i
feel like
but well
um
there's
follow instagram we've been working
really hard on it we're really super
proud of it and we're really excited for
it and we can't wait for you guys to get
it and we pushed really hard to make
sure it was out for christmas yeah is
the what we mean to say
yeah except me doing instagram
and i felt weird like
today's the day yeah this is our launch
day how do we how do you drop an ad on
this [ __ ] episode it's almost
impossible
but
we appreciate it i don't even mind not
doing hands or teleport like i said
yesterday if the ad read partners get
weird like then [ __ ] cancel the
contract yeah if that's what makes you
feel weird [ __ ] you
and i don't mind it
let's do double ads and another one who
gives a [ __ ]
yeah
we'll figure it out i'm not i'm not
tripping over that [ __ ] at all yeah
one thing i don't want to let my do
myself do is just get like get caught up
and
i just want to really keep control of my
mind because when you're in a situation
like this your mind can
i having gone through it many before
like
there has to be i mean it's normal to
grieve it's normal to do all that but
i'm i want to be really mindful of a
couple things i need to take it and this
next big chapter in my life i need to
take really good care of myself
my like really not just go on stretches
of like eating good and exercising and
[ __ ] taking care of myself i need to not
let anything come between me and my
daughter that she goes through and she's
a teenager
like that's
i need those goals i can't let any
elephants in the room
i can't let [ __ ] go unsaid
and i've been moving like that i've been
very outspoken
but it means the
that's the main thing i think to pull
from it is like i never want to have
unsaid [ __ ] with my kids
you kids seem to be pretty stable bro
pretty good like you guys
you're doing fine
you know what i'm saying
you have a backsplash
yeah that was guys guys crushing it i
know
yesterday
this is such a [ __ ]
first world problem or whatever i know i
get it but it's like
i couldn't tell my kids about this
yesterday all we had the people
installing the backsplash in my house
starting about a half hour after i got
the call
so we got you know a crew of uh mexican
dudes down in the main floor of the
house all day installing our backsplash
which came out awesome the white dude
upstairs is just screaming at the walls
he's pissed about something
yeah so april had to facilitate that
while i was just like in my room
thinking about all this and then we
didn't tell the kids until night time
yeah yeah you were nice enough to send
some pizzas and [ __ ] it was a bomb yeah
it was awesome i don't know where rosie
ordered it it was great the fact that
pizza showed up at the most iconic time
like the guy hit us i was like i dropped
to the door
i did yeah
ariana's always like thomas is the best
friend ever
yeah that that was big because i was
[ __ ] starving i didn't eat all day
until that i already knew it i'm like
you guys are not going to want to cook
right now we had just april 1 got
groceries we had just pushed our fridge
in they delivered our goddamn more
i was going to say white people problems
first world problems they delivered the
[ __ ] new fridge we got on sleds okay
skis imagine it being on two skis that
were
that are [ __ ] drilled into it
take that off we had to it involved two
trips to home depot to get the right
ratchet sockets it involves me tipping
back the [ __ ] fridge in april
underneath well she does it oh no
so we had the fridge just in the kitchen
for a couple days until we had all that
we just put the [ __ ] fridge back in
so we have a fridge now
and uh we have the backsplash now the
kitchen is almost done we got to put the
hood up in front of the [ __ ] oven
yeah and then it'll basically be done
but yeah we couldn't even really
yeah they were all there all day
yesterday doing that and
so just pretending that the kids were
what's up dad yeah i know nothing
that it was kind of like that
so
yeah we had to tell him last night what
a predicament to be in like
i'll tell you in 12 hours [ __ ] yeah it
kind of worked out good it did yeah to
not have to go through all april did all
the talking
april's just been an angel throughout
all this the whole thing is the [ __ ]
through line basically
she's way more mature than me she's more
wait you just said that right now and
when april's episode she knows i'm gonna
bring up this clip she's more mature
than me
on that screen while we all watch it
yeah see [ __ ] i give her credit
she gave me she was giving me really
solid effort she's always giving me
amazing advice for my mom even when my
mom wasn't treating her nicely
good which is like
who my mom wanted to be ironically
right but in her letter she took out a
whole separate section for april like
she should have she was a [ __ ]
angel the whole time and really was
better than
better than i was
because she didn't she wasn't all pissed
off like i was yeah she was only
thinking about the kids she's better
than at that than me
she thinks about well also she'll rub
your grudge off grudge holding off on
you too so
it's not all you it's what you were
raised in yeah you know i've actually
grown out of it yeah i'm actively trying
to not be like that yeah for sure
it's it's hard but it's not
you just have to check yourself every
time you feel like you're doing some
dumb [ __ ] yeah there's a difference
between holding a grudge
and just not
like i'm at peace with this situation
we're all good here but i just don't
care about you we're just not we're not
connected anymore that's that's exactly
it like we'll go with you somebody that
we talked about in my first episode
reached out to me after it came out
and apologized that's right and i was
like i really [ __ ] appreciate you
doing that
thank you
not to say
bam you're all back in my life again and
we're all [ __ ] homeboys but
i'm glad we're both at peace with this
we're not walking around [ __ ] mad
over nothing at each other because i'm
not
that's crazy bro
so yeah that's the big thing like that
that builds up over time i said it
earlier that
leads to cancer and [ __ ] or it leads to
situations like this where it's like we
don't know what's going on it's just
like
it just builds and manifests in your in
your body and and
it's i think it's part of us being here
we gotta that's part of being human is
is to learn to get through
[ __ ] like that hard [ __ ] in life
it's part of our job to get through it
and not let it take us out
good way to put it yeah
it's a great way to put a bumper sticker
man yeah she put in her letter like it's
you know you're here to learn
and when i'm done i'll have a life
review oh she dropped some insightful
[ __ ] she's put all that in her letter
and i'll
i'll look back on the things i could
have did better and the things where i
had my successes or whatever
you know i mean
i don't [ __ ] know what happens when
you die i'm not gonna act like i do
but
in a lot of ways she had a healthy way
of looking at it
but then there was just this next level
to it yeah that took it to a place of
weirdness and like
me not knowing what the [ __ ] is going on
but good man glad you're glad you got to
talk about this yeah it sounds good
thank you yeah i don't know how much
time has been but
i think if you got everything off your
chest i think that's good i think we
anymore we're just gonna start
you just start [ __ ] dwelling on your
own thoughts and [ __ ] yeah no i think
that's all i really wanted to talk about
and i'm gonna go watch the bills
hopefully let's see trying to be
confident
edit this thing and get it out when it's
ready and we're gonna move on to this
next episode next episodes and
i'm probably gonna have to go to texas
for a while
to figure [ __ ] out and
i don't know what's gonna happen with
this attorney situation the last thing i
want to deal with is yeah think about
some malpractice
negligence lawsuit
but
i think that is the case
i don't even want to like
yeah that's a whole i haven't even let
myself tap into that yet
but
the way my aunt was talking about it and
april's mom like
so [ __ ] up
that's a whole nother thing to worry
about right now now it's just
getting the [ __ ] done that you had to
get done for personal stuff so
like i said when you hire the movers bro
you have to be there
yeah we'll figure it out yeah
good [ __ ] thank you guys
it's really cool having a community yeah
especially people that are going through
some
or have gone through things too because
first i mean literally one of the first
things i thought about was the [ __ ]
show
it's like well now you can breathe and
[ __ ] well not even about that like it
wasn't one of the first things i thought
about but it was just like
damn we're gonna miss an episode we've
never missed there's no way i can we
were supposed to record yesterday i know
but i'm not i knew like we were gonna
put up a clip yeah family emergency
sorry i see i was totally ready to not
do it yeah but i just i just i told you
that you want to do this there's no
other
time in history that
i'll be able to look back at this my
kids will be able to look back at this
other kids going through this shouldn't
be able to look at it yeah there's no
other time
yes it's like we could address it with
our [ __ ] guests yeah and people are
going through the same thing you were
going through in high school right now
with your dad yeah you're going through
my [ __ ] cousin memphis just went
through the [ __ ] uncle john yeah like
this [ __ ] all same [ __ ] age
yeah this [ __ ] this happens
daily some people right now are thinking
about their friends dad or their friends
my like [ __ ]
and then you have to d you mean like
having to console your homies i don't
even think about that i know i started
yesterday as my boys from buffalo are
messaging me and said i'm like they know
her too
yeah we used to hang out in the basement
that's your mom bro she i'm seeing you
know what i mean like
we're getting to that age where it's
like [ __ ] people are homies parents are
getting old oh [ __ ] because you don't
think about when you're 15 16.
you do not think about that [ __ ] now
it's like
oh [ __ ]
now i'm where you're at when i met you
so that's crazy boy yeah that was fast
the [ __ ] thing goes fast these are
slow after that it's [ __ ] not mmm
twenties are slow cause you're trying to
figure out what you're doing it's true
slow shockers [ __ ] yeah i couldn't wait
to get out of my car
people asked me like you're getting
always feel weird like i don't ever want
to be 20s again i felt
deep in my 30s in my 20s yeah
there you go
about 29 i went
i'm [ __ ] over it can i just buy some
houses yeah i'm over this i can smoke
weed while i'm [ __ ] searching they're
never houses working on my [ __ ] i'm
[ __ ] tired of just smoking weed all
day every day with nothing leaving
yeah you know what you mean because i
was just getting high doing videos
you're like money
you don't have that like i'm gonna go
out and party get that out of my system
for a couple years
man i went downtown to when i was like
19 we'd go down to a club once in a
while and i
i don't know if i'm
like an [ __ ] i feel like an [ __ ] i
feel i feel like like something's about
to happen
i feel like i hate it dude i'm like can
we just wait for the [ __ ]
i'm gonna start dancing i gotta leave
can i [ __ ] leave yeah that's how i
feel every time i go to anything i feel
like i'm going to stand here just look
like a mean mug and everybody but i'm
really just really just like i kind of
smoke a joint here yeah
that's how i feel man i hate clubs i
hate nightclubs i hate [ __ ] bars i
don't like that [ __ ] yeah i don't know
if i have to do that at all no i didn't
either even when i was deep in music i
[ __ ] hated clubs yeah i'm good
for what yeah
but i mean i guess it's cool do you
think but yeah maybe sometimes but yeah
i don't know how the [ __ ] we got on that
topic don't know it's all right but
this has been an episode know what to
call it but
here we are yeah
good [ __ ] appreciate you sir i
appreciate all the fans
all right i think we close it up we'll
move up we'll move on from this and
chapter
three
yeah ready supposed to be a challenge
we'll see what happens
nothing but positive things setting more
[ __ ] goals trying to get [ __ ] out
there
we're gonna crush it man we're we're one
month away from crushing the [ __ ] out of
the next year
i know that oh yeah
i know that it's really surreal to get
it it's surreal to know that as a
[ __ ] fact in fact
i'm ready cause i'm just grateful i'm
just i'm just grateful to just be in
position yep that everything worked out
despite all this
it's working out it's crazy how
it's like
i told you like these these are like
monumental points in your these numbers
and dates and [ __ ] coming up on your
[ __ ] is crazy
the chapters your life closing and
everything's just starting to work
same here
we're on the same path bro what i'm
saying
but
in different ways
i don't know but
yeah good [ __ ] cool good afternoon go
bells go bills
guys it's been an episode of the dope as
usual podcast have a dope ass day
i thought we're gonna smoke way more i
was like man i'm about to have about
seven blunts right there
[Music]
perfect perfect
[Music]